a Stargate Announcement by May the 1st
or
it won't be this year
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular soundtrack
you'll know I've been telling you for
I've got nearly seven months now that
this was really going to be the crunch
point for this Stargate announcement we
really hoped that we would get to see
something in January time when the Slate
for this year got announced at MGM but
we didn't we've now learned that
actually there's lots of conversations
and indecision going on at Amazon and
actually a big part of this problem was
that we were waiting for MGM and Amazon
to get a new head of film that happened
a couple of weeks ago and then it looked
like again the decision had been made
when Courtney Valentini was ordered by
Jennifer selke to Begin work on a movie
however it looks now like there is still
indecision going on and I'm going to
tell you in a little while why there is
actually some competition at Amazon
between who wants to do the movie and
who wants to do the TV series and that
is causing even more confrontation
but there is also the looming strike and
how that has already impacted Stargate
but might impact it even more so yes
there has been a little bit of a perfect
storm that Stargate has been caught in
the middle of right now the problem is
simply this the God of War was greenlit
nearly a year ago it was actually
greenlit and the development work
started and the contractual stuff the
conversations between Studios started
last January it didn't then get
announced until what was it August but
when it did get announced Sony Pictures
was already on board penguin and Parker
was on board and Amazon had ordered the
series
the problem we have at the moment is
that Amazon hasn't struck that deal up
God of War they struck a deal with Sony
pictures for Stargate they haven't
struck a deal with a studio
the problem is there are two Studios
competing for the Stargate franchise
Warner Brothers really want to do this
and they're pushing for a movie first
Jennifer sulky really likes this idea
MGM has a good previous working
relationship with Warner Brothers
but Amazon has a better working
relationship with so many pictures and
so many pictures want to do this but
they want to do a TV series both
companies have a history working with
Mark Fergus and are more than happy to
go in that direction
Mark fergus's penguin and Parker is
currently working with Sony pictures on
the God of War Series so that sort of
give sewning in as well now this whole
Sony connection is new we didn't know
about this and it just complicates the
picture even more and the God of War TV
series has been of delay for Stargate
because penguin and Parker having to get
all these scripts done for the God of
War before the possible writer's strike
now this writer strike which I've
mentioned in a previous video is looming
large right now the big nine Studios
have got Representatives currently
talking to all the different writers
guilds they're trying to beat out a
resolution to this problem and if they
don't the deadline is May the 1st and if
a solution isn't met by then the writers
of America for TV and film will go on
strike now I don't know if you guys
remember but this has happened a couple
of times before and it put loads of TV
shows on its ass what we did what we
ended up getting for a year was We got
like half seasons of stuff instead of
full series got stuff canceled got stuff
put back movies got delayed etc etc
because the writers even though they
might scribble away at home are not
allowed to put anything any scripts in
officially they have to go on strike and
Mark Ferguson hall Coast be are in the
same boat if the scripts of the God of
War aren't done by May 1st and they do
go on strike
they can't do any more work on it and
that just delays the project even more
but that's having a knock-on effect with
Stargate because Hawk host being Mark
Fergus are having to concentrate on the
God of War if they get the scripts done
by May the 1st and there's a strike they
can carry on working on the God of War
they are allowed to continue their
executive producer role in that respect
and the God of War can move forwards and
then hopefully they'd be able to start
concentrating on Stargate a little more
so why am I saying that there's a May
the first deadline for Stargate
I was told
um before Christmas well before
Christmas to be fair and by somebody
that I really trust that it was really
down to April
if April very early may we didn't have
an official announcement to Stargate
then the chances are Amazon would push
it back to next year's slate they would
not bother with it this year they would
just say look it's next year's problem
now let's continue the development work
let's continue having conversational
Studios but it's not happening this year
we are obviously right on the cusp of
that deadline it still means I think the
Stargate will happen but the more delays
we get the higher the risk that actually
this just might not happen or might not
happen now it could be another decade
and if it is then we're going to get a
hard reboot and that is that is just
this way of it Battlestar Galactica is
the perfect example there was a big
enough Gap we've got a hard reboot
nobody really complained too much and
there are people at Amazon and MGM that
would prefer a hard reboot for Stargate
so for them the more time that goes by
the older the actors from the original
series get so you know fans can't really
complain about Richard Dean Anderson
coming back if he's 90. even Amanda
Tapping Michael Shanks etc etc if
they're pushing 60 70
they're not going to return
and a continuation becomes more and more
impractical
so that is one of my things another fear
though is that this just might not
happen at all it could just get shelved
all of these plans all of these
conversations all of this debate could
actually just go onto a shelf and gather
dust
How likely do I think that is
now it's very unlikely look at the
amount of Interest now I guess you got
to look at the amount of times we have
trended on Twitter
Amazon know that there's a massive
interest in Stargate and it will happen
it's just when
will it be a hard reboot or not so may
the 1st it's only three weeks away how
worried should we be
I speak to a couple of people obviously
in the industry one person has said to
me very clearly look they're just
waiting on the right to strike as soon
as they know what's happening we write a
strike it's getting announced so don't
worry
another person that I spoke to that I
was speaking to a long time said they
don't think it's going to happen this
year they think it'll actually now end
up getting announced next year in the
early MGM plus when they announced all
their slates for the coming year he
thinks that's now when that's gonna
happen
what do I think
I'm nervous
I've had phases over the last 12 months
where I've become very confident the
Stargate was going to happen and I've
told you guys when I was very confident
it was going to happen I've then had
faces where I've become
nervous I'm in a nervous period at the
moment that might be because
so close we can taste it it's it's just
there
I Now understand the industry a lot more
for example the God of War thing I knew
God of War was happening with penguin
and Parker in January
it had gone so long until it actually
got announced that I'd forgotten about
it when it got announced I was genuinely
surprised I was like oh they're doing
god of war with penguin and Parker and
then they told me oh yeah I knew that
it's these things do take time and I I
get it
but being able to see behind the curtain
like we have done with Stargate being
able to see all the different
discussions and arguments going on and
just seeing how long it does take
is making me nervous I'm genuinely
getting to the point where I generally I
honestly can't think how Holly would get
anything done if this is how long it
takes to do all these things
but from a business point of view I
suppose I do understand that setting up
a partnership to do any project that
costs hundreds of millions of dollars
does take time even the God of War as I
say took eight to nine months
for Amazon to get an agreement with Sony
and penguin in a park in place and get
to a point where they could announce it
it's then going to be another at least
six months until we get any casting
information it'll then be probably
another couple of months after that
until they actually start filming and
maybe a year after that until it appears
on our screens
so
maybe we shouldn't be surprised that
this is the roller coaster it is but it
doesn't make it any less frustrating
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you're thinking this may the
first deadline do you think it's now or
never
do you think actually that if we go past
the May the first and we haven't had an
official announcement that it's actually
very likely we're going to get the hard
reboot we all dread and that it might
not be till
2030.
God knows
again to come soon and tell me exactly
what you're thinking are you as nervous
as me
scale of one to ten I'm like nine losing
fingernails over it that sort of thing
it's not nice
but if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps designed
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos you can also go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where for a
small contribution each month you can
see videos like this first and without
the adverts and obviously that
contribution really helps the channel
you'll also get to see patreon only
videos you know uncut stuff and things
just for you
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]